the EU has today approved 500 million
euros worth of military aid for Ukraine
but all eyes are still on Berlin as
pressure mounts to supply german-made
leopard tanks to the country Poland and
Finland say they're ready to give the
vehicles to Ukraine but Jeremy holds the
export license required to pass them on
and is concerned about the move
escalating this war in a growing split
several Ukrainian allies have rejected
this position arguing there is no good
reason why battle tanks shouldn't be
provided uh well one such country is
Latvia he's prime minister critiana's
Karens joins me now live from Riga thank
you so much for taking the time this
afternoon we really appreciate it here
on Sky News perhaps
um in this latest development in
supplying
um weapons and equipment to Ukraine you
can explain to us where Latvia stands
right now
uh Latvia stance is a very clear Ukraine
needs weapons to win the war this is the
war by Russia against Ukraine it's a war
of imperialism that means they are back
in the old game of uh territorial
conquest and apparently just basically
trying to annihilate the Ukrainian
nation in all ways we have to understand
that if you Ukraine does not win then
everyone has a huge problem because
Russia there's no indication that it
would stop or it was it would be
interested in stopping so we have to
help Ukraine stop Russia and that can
only be done with the supplying of
weapons we've been doing so since before
the war started we have been supplying
as much as we can we're about one
percent of our GDP in our military aid
then we have Grassroots Aid coming from
all segments of our society with
vehicles generators Food Equipment
medical equipment doctors also helping
out so so it's a full National effort to
Aid the ukrainians because we understand
they are fighting the war in all of our
places they are defending a freedom and
democracy and the right to National
sovereignty and they deserve and they
need our help yeah they need so much Aid
of all different forms but the the focus
does very much seem to be on the supply
of tanks and president zielinski said
look this is what we need to not just
maintain the status quo and survive but
to thrive and go on to win this war
countries like yourself are offering up
tanks the UK but it's head above the
parapet first and said that it would
Supply a number of Tanks between 12 and
14. but people are looking at Berlin and
Germany not coming forward to provide
their tanks what do you think the
reasoning is behind that in terms of
Germany not standing with you to to send
tanks directly to Ukraine
well let's remember that Germany has 70
almost 80-year history of pacifism uh
prior to this war and I think that maybe
it's it's taken a little bit of time to
sort of rethink that position uh
certainly
one has to admit that Germany uh has
been supplying all kinds of uh Aid to
Ukraine including very important anti-uh
aircraft assistance the Patriot another
german-made system so this is all a very
uh good and necessary but it's also
clear uh that zelenski is saying that
they need the uh uh offensive weapons to
drive the Russians out of their
territory and it basically comes down to
uh more heavy equipment we're giving the
heaviest equipment that we have we don't
have these main battle tanks we've given
them uh howitzers we're giving them
Stingers we're helping to train them uh
drones etc etc but if we can give one
percent of our GDP in military aid well
then certainly other countries can do
the same and those that have the heavy
equipment I think it's a a moral
responsibility to let that equipment
help Ukraine expel an Invader and this
is very clear uh that that is simply
what we as a democratic countries we
have to Aid one another Ukraine is now
under incredible pressure and uh
zielinski is right they do not need only
to endure uh this atrocity they need to
win the war
um I take on board your point about the
historical context of Germany wanting to
supply tanks to another country is an
extremely
sensitive issue for that country
can the tanks be effective though
without German involvement I think it
was the German Minister for economic
Affairs he said there's a difference
between making a decision of your own
accord and hindering the decision of
others Jeremy's saying look we've got no
problem we hold the license but if you
want to send those tanks to Ukraine
we're not going to stand in your way
but will Ukraine get what it needs if
Germany don't send their tanks because
we're talking about numbers here
president zielinski saying you know we
need numbers of Tanks we just don't we
don't need 10 from one country 10 for
another we need the numbers is Germany
vital to the success of that well
Germany is Europe's largest economy
Germany has one heck of a potential of
course from the continent we have the
the UK we have France we have other
countries giving a lot it's but for the
effort to really be successful
from the European point of view we need
Germany fully on board and I think it's
it's it's important for all of us that
we we have a unity in Europe right now
in the EU across NATO uh this is very
important that we keep it we have to
endure but they are sometimes very tough
decisions internally to take for many
countries uh uh countries are sending
there's stockpiles which are meant for
their own defense moving them into
Ukraine so these are these are very
tough decisions to take but they're
necessary decisions and I think it's
quite important that Germany is fully in
line with all the rest of us and
Germany's potential uh certainly
compared to my own country is is a quite
quite a difference 80 million versus 2
million so it's very important that
Germany is fully on board in the
meantime you're pressing ahead with your
individual actions as a nation in terms
of supplying Ukraine particularly with
tanks and you're banding together with
another of other Eastern European
countries to to form a coalition if you
like to to send those out there and give
the country what it needs how quickly
can you get them there because we keep
hearing about how there needs to be
training time involved you know it takes
a while to get the tanks into position
how quickly can you move on this to make
it effective for Ukraine
uh once again just to be precise if we
had tanks we would send them we don't
have tanks we have houses we've sent the
howitzers in terms of training this is
something that uh needs to be uh ongoing
all the time we have trained in the past
we're training now we will train in the
future but I don't think that it's it
can work as an excuse because the
Ukrainian military has proven time and
time again that they are extremely Adept
at learning new systems adapting those
new systems taking care maintaining
those new systems they have our trust
and we need to uh really let them uh
work and all of the the Practical issues
they can be solved uh what is difficult
is overcoming the political decision the
political decision has to be clear a
green light to give Ukraine all that we
have each of us individually
individually and then collectively that
is what uh Ukraine needs so the training
can be done uh they're using Patriot
systems so you using the German I think
it's called the Isis system the anti-air
they're using all kinds of houses
including the ones that we've given them
uh they're they're learning all kinds of
new weapon systems and by the end of
this war they'll be teaching us uh how
best to use them yeah prime minister
indeed thank you so much for your time
as the Prime Minister of Latvia their
christianis Karens here on Sky News
talking about the setting of equipment
to ukrainees to European countries
coming together to send military
equipment and Aid